uh she did make a list of all the things
she wants out of a new career so
what kind of a job would she be doing
specifically
did you say specifically
yeah as in
like get specific about the tasks that
she'd be doing come on Ron Bud write a
book
well should have about six people
reporting to her get to be my own boss
so far so good also uh what would this
sock options be
is it like she provides her own socks
you provide the socks for her yeah Andy
I think she probably meant stock options
stock options
it's a privately held company Ben
anyway
April Ludgate Dwyer she worked on that
Grizzle deal you guys did the finances
for oh of course I liked her very much
real no-nonsense attitude the cost
projections are in appendix two I'm
still waiting on those real estate
holdings people here they are that
should complete the list of gristle's
assets thanks Frank you do great work
for someone that died 200 years ago
okay next card that comes I'm gonna
pretend to be a valet and get the keys
and I'm going to put these in the
passenger seat some idiot is going to
open his car door and be like what
lobsters I just got so pranked what kind
of a genius pulled off this prank me
I'll say Andy Dwyer he'll say how'd you
like to work for me son at the White
House I'm like are you serious nope he
was pranking me go hide
April upgate hey Pete is that your car
yeah yeah hey great work on that
forestry service memo thanks Pete
bancroftall who I work with give me your
keys I'll wait here because I'm waiting
here anyway and I will just make sure
that no one puts anything weird in your
car great I'll see you in there see you
in there am I doing it we can't put
lobsters in his car I work with him
that's probably the best I'm gonna let
him go
they like to hide under stuff like rocks
Animal Planet oh check it out these
Grizzle techs are brain jamming on the
new Grizzle MD it's this patch that
monitors your temperature syncs with
your medical records and then makes
doctor's appointments for you here roll
up your sleeve
you need more vitamin D
ude it's true baby never go outside okay
my turn
you eat too much sugar you are deficient
in nearly every vitamin you need more
sleep you have never flossed what this
thing is buggy you guys need to fix the
technology
so wait you guys are not against us on
this we're not against you on this we're
not against you on this wow this is
amazing this is unanimous support I've
had dreams about this counterpoints
counterpoints grizzle's the best okay
there's no such thing as privacy anymore
everything should be open to the public
full transparency in fact I'll read my
internet browser history right now
Illuminati Bilderberg Group Agenda 21
Leslie note marital status Leslie nope
feet all right Morris hit the bricks
okay you know what you guys can boo me
uh guess what I've been live streaming
this entire thing and putting it on to a
website for perverts okay so enjoy your
debate about privacy sheeple
damn okay don't pay any attention to
Morris us up we are united we can
take them down
data mining slapping with the seasoned
assist order
don't worry baby it's like shooting fish
in a barrel you sure you don't want to
do this yourself oh no no no no no live
TV is still
living in the world I mean just singing
on the air sign makes my tongue feel
spiky and it's gonna be glorious you'll
probably win an award for this or a
statue maybe they'll name City Hall
after you oh you know what you jerk I
don't want that to be my honor well I
guess you deserved it whatever I love
you is it because I submitted to the New
Yorker cartoon caption contest under
your name look they said that you could
only submit 10 captions per cartoon
which is borderline fascists and I
needed some pseudonyms is that it no go
away well you won twice I'll have you
now talk to me come on Ron talk to me
hey you talking to me you will talk to
me nine you're talking to me
Serbian you don't know a Serbian accent
Come on talk to me
you're talking to me
hey my name is
um I'm sorry Ah that's nice run I'm very
stubborn and I real butthead ah right
that's not nice say about yourself but
it's true Pawnee water torture
one word
and this is over trip
let's see how much we have left
[Music]
food
you look very crazy right now I'm
starving I missed second dinner and
first snack and second snack and third
dinner I looked everywhere and this is
the only thing I could find what is it
is it five steaks it's a Sweden's
chocolate slamo bar there's no actual
food in these they couldn't even legally
use the word chocolate the expiration
date is don't worry about it you want
half I would prefer to eat the entire
thing oh would you why should we both
remain mostly hungry instead of one of
us being full let's flip for it or
better I can devise a contest of some
kind and the winner gets the full
chocolate slammo bar or we could split
it like everyone else in the world would
do in our situation splitting is
communist why don't you just break off
45 of it send it to the government and
then you and I can try to make do with
whatever's left over why don't I smash
it in my fist and shove it up your nose
so I don't have to hear another goofball
libertarian lecture from you yes
self-reliance is a goofball philosophy
not Democratic socialism you know what I
don't even want to just take it
there's nowhere to run Ron you have
tried every possible means of Escape
there's nothing to do but talk
wait where are you going damn it Ron you
can't keep running away
what are you doing
a secret compartment I secret
compartments when did you make that
first day I had the job we're going to
talk about our feelings
I'm gonna need a drink hi sorry I'm late
warm Summer Breeze red velvet cake Kyra
Sedgwick Parks and Rec interns can
accomplish amazing things April Ludgate
here was an intern 10 years ago before
blazing a trail to the National Park
Service that's uh
that's a decade
amazing look how much you've
accomplished April tell these youngsters
here what's in store for them
you know Craig I think a simple welcome
speech isn't enough I like to spend a
couple days with these guys really get
to know them that's amazing bed bugs
when I get too happy I say one bad thing
to cool myself off
great job Burley you know natural town
like you could use an agent what do you
think wow yeah maybe I'd like to spend
some time with you first though to see
if we like uh
great job bud you crushed it hey thanks
man it's all pretend
you know that right yeah let's go meet
with your station manager I'm gonna get
you a better deal you're a star Eddie
you don't need to be doing a bunch of
extra jobs for no money you're totally
right you're totally right I just need a
few minutes uh I gotta sweep up put away
some props and I still have to place the
pyrotechnics for the third act finale
Andy no let's go
great tactic make them think your walk
I'm serious I'm gonna walk you better
attack to make them think you're serious
about walking the show's meant to be
it'll work out you taught me stand up
for myself that's what I'm doing hey
stand up yourself till you get a bunch
of money then you sit down on your big
pile of money
no walking for you rich man hey Eddie
you're still walking either way I love
it power move
hey guys mommy and I just need to talk
can you quiet down please I will give
you each a billion dollars
forget it they have my energy and your
focus we created monsters well they're
cute monsters adorable that's how they
get you so help me out with this I have
been stressing about my Newport land
proposal I think we need to find a way
to sex it up I don't know what could be
sexier than the intricacies of federal
land purchases I know you're joking but
that actually does turn me on the New
Ports aren't going to just donate this
land we're going to have to sweeten the
deal just like tonight
sneaking broccoli into the mac and
cheese so the children don't know that
they're eating vegetables so parenting
is all about helping your children
through lies well not just your children
I've been sneaking vegetables into your
waffles for years now since way before
we were married
what haven't you ever wondered why your
syrup had seeds in it you said they were
maple seeds yeah
there's no such thing
I have literally never been angrier at
anyone in my life walk away Wyatt
all right